Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am Rawkode, your host and today
we are gonna take a look at Thanos.
Now before we move on to that, I
just wanna take ten seconds to say thank
you to Equinix Medal, my employer
for giving me the time and the resources
to be able to invest in producing these
materials so that we can all learn together.
If you wanna play with Equinix Metal, the
bare metal cloud, you can use a code,
Rawkode live for $50 in credit.
There's a whole array of configurations of bare
metal machines that you can use and play
with. If you can spend that money very
very quickly or you can be a little
bit more conservative and make it last up
to one hundred hours with our smallest instances.
If you're not watching this live or you
just like this card, feel free to join
the chat. We have loads of people in
there. We always talk about the episodes and
what's happening and it's a really good way
for you to suggest potential new episodes too.
Please remember to subscribe to our channel. This
helps the content get and more people, more
people can learn and that makes it more
fun for me too.
And today, we're gonna take a look at
Thanos.
Now I am joined
by who
is a contributor
and maintainer of the Thanos project. Hello. How
are you?
Hello. Hello. I'm fine. Thank you for having
me here.
Awesome.
It's gonna be really good fun. I'm looking
forward to to understanding more about Thanos and
and what problem it's trying to solve and
and and how it's gonna help me in
my kind of monitoring observability
and Kubernetes journey.
Do you want to just take a little
moment to tell us a little bit about
you, what you do, and your involvement in
the project?
Sure.
So my name my full name is actually
Bartlomi
port Bartlomi Podka, and that's how you pronounce
it in Polish. I'm from Poland, but you
can always call me Bartek. It's just simpler.
Currently, I am a principal software engineer at
Red Hat responsible for some observability
things
for Red Hat open OpenShift and beyond.
And to be honest, my career was
kind of always around observability,
more or less.
You know, the beginning, it was at Intel.
I was really doing some noise neighbor. I
was scheduling for OpenStack,
Mesos, Kubernetes, whatever was, you know, the most
popular
back then.
Then a series at and closed on start
up where
we actually were using Prometheus a lot. This
is where I started to use Prometheus.
We actually use it that much that we
wanted to scale it out and we couldn't,
so we created Thanos
on the on the site, let's say,
which growed
grown a little bit.
And that's how I started to be kind
of Thanos
culture and and and maintainer
as well and getting into this community.
And right now, we are we are continuing
this journey.
And, also,
there is new
special interest group in the CNCF
space, which is called observability,
which I'm tech leading. So please join us
there as well
if you want to contribute more to those
projects around observability.
So that's me. Yeah. And I live in
London if
we have time for and and kind of
opportunity for some meetups at some point.
Hopefully, we can continue doing that.
Yeah. It sounds like you keep yourself busy.
There's a lot of things that you're involved
with there. You know, lead tech lead for
Kubernetes
or CNCF's sake. We've contributed to the multiple
projects. Like, how do you find the time
for all of this?
Scheduling, you know.
No no time to waste.
Well, I guess it's 2020 and we can't
leave the house so that must be Exactly.
Yeah. That would have contributed to that. Yeah.
Okay.
So
I believe you've got a few slides. You're
gonna run us through a quick introduction to
Thanos. So while you just get your screen
ready,
we have a few comments. So Vikas says
he is excited.
Vanessa, hello. Hi there.
Namaste.
Oh, you got a hello as well. Hi
there. Hello.
And there we go. That's all of our
introductions.
So
your screen is now visible.
So what is Thanos?
Cool. So
don't be mad if I will be kind
of going through slides maybe quicker. I don't
want to spend too much time on, like,
details. I remember you also
David, you had, like, previous talk with Cortex,
which is, you know which which really described
the problem with Prometheus and kind of similar
goals as Thanos have. So I won't go
very into details. But at the end, all
starts with, you know, your application. You are
running applications somewhere,
some infrastructure,
and you want to, you know, have some
information about that. You want to leverage and
and take some data and know, you know,
how is it working?
Is it actually working with everyone? How fast?
You know, what it's doing, resources,
and also some some things
trying to predict future. You know? How much
you know, is it going to maybe be
saturated soon? Maybe don't know if that doesn't
have enough disk and stuff like that. How
it performs long term versus maybe how it
perform
at some point before.
And all of this is much more, you
know, complex to gather and and learn once
you are in the communities. Right? You you
essentially have all those layers that you need
to monitor as well on the way. Lots
of sidecars, lots of proxies, and and so
on. So
this is why observability
and monitoring is is crucial. It should be
kind of your your default, and it goes
even even further to saying, you know, there
is no application, no product if you have
no monitoring because
it's, like, not running the product at all
because you you don't know if it's running,
right, ever. So
and and we can, you know, kind of
it was mentioned a couple of times in
the SRE book as well. Like, it is
kind of foundation of running an infrastructure
and monitoring observability
to detect detect stuff, detect issues,
to automate stuff, really. Right?
And
going further, we we know, you know, in
observability, we have different signals, we call it.
And this is kind of the,
let's say, the formal kind of description
of this. We have traces, logs, and metrics.
And but that's not the end, by the
way. We have a couple new signals coming
on, continuous profiling,
and
all of these are kind of part of
the observability
that we we are responsible for in in
the CNCFSY coxerality, for example. And we have
lots of different projects supporting
those.
And
one use case of those observability again is,
like, troubleshooting journey. Right? You've probably seen that
graph a lot. You first getting an alert
for your app
being broken or something is going on. You
go to dashboarding.
Maybe you query your metrics first.
Then you go to log aggregation if you
don't know yet what's wrong and then to
distribute the tracing if that fails. Right? And,
hopefully, you have some solution at the end.
And we will focus kind of today
the first part. So alerting metrics, aggregation, and,
like, kind of
numeric values, numeric informations that you can you
can gather over time using primitive Thanos
systems.
Right?
And what is Thanos? A Thanos is essentially
a horizontally scalable metric monitoring system
which solves
couple of
limitations that that that single Prometheus have. And,
really, as as Ganesh mentioned in a in
a Cortex session here, it's really exactly the
same.
It's it's really around running multiple Prometheus servers.
Right? Because
it is just designed as a single, you
know, binary that is very, very powerful, Prometheus,
I mean.
But it
at some point, you need to scale out.
Right? You need to run multiple clusters maybe.
You'll need to run
maybe some higher availability of the prompt use.
Maybe you need to functionally shard it.
And and so and maybe you want to
have to tell the other system that just
pushes
and backfills metric from from other sources. Right?
And all of this was was the reason
why Thanos was created as well
to solve all those issues.
And on top of that,
Prometheus was not really designed for long term
metrics
kind of storage and and and querying and
using.
That's why we
we kind of designed something like downsampling, which
allows much, much faster using of this long
like, one year or two years worth of
data, for example, and overall kind of cheap
and a nice experience of using those.
So very quickly,
you can think about Thanos as
primitive but
distributed.
Right? So we pick all of those components
and just
scale it out and, you know, horizontal scale
them. So just from high level view, primitive
is nothing more than just single box with
just, you know, some rule and alerting engine,
query engine, compaction,
scrape engine, storage,
much more probably, but, you know, those are
the core things.
And what we did with Thanos, we we
split really
and and, usually, we we're really using the
same code sometimes.
And we split that into separate services, separate
component that you can configure and flexibly flexibly
deploy
in different kind of
model.
So you can run them in different clusters,
different, you know, kind of spots, and and
horizontal scale them. So, you know, the query
engine becomes Thanos querier. You can you can
put it anywhere. You can find out the
queries and and have global view.
The scrape engine becomes
really just Prometheus. You can use Prometheus as
a scrape engine and very
so it's it's a very lightweight
in a very lightweight way as well because
usually,
Prometheus is buffy. But with Thanos, you can
just have, like, super short retention of your
data
on the Prometheus side, keep it very light,
and
store
kind of your data in the object storage
of your of your choice.
And
and allow PromptUs to to be really just
collector. Right?
Thanos
alerting and and rules engine becomes Thanos
becomes global compactor because now it has to
compact and downsample and do this managing
maintenance stuff on top of bucket.
And we have some object storage that permit
to use uploads the data too, which so
we need some component that fetches that data
from the buckets. So
that's that's really it in the in a
very high level view.
And, hopefully, during the session, we can we
can learn more
hands on, really,
with running those those those components and and
playing with them.
But at the end, it's it's really a
monitoring system that that is flexible enough to
to be composed as you want with those
components, query start with compact sidecar receiver.
Receiver is the one that that probably we
won't have time to cover, but, essentially, receiver
allows you to
remote ride the data from Prometheus
to centralized Thanos.
Maybe we'll have time to cover this. Let's
see.
But at the end, I want to leverage
and and highlight kind of one important
kind of flexibility point here. It's all possible
because we have, like, consistent API across this
those components. So you can think of it
that those core components of Prometheus were split
into, you know, horizontal scalable
services,
but they all kind of communicate with with
the same consistent gRPC interface,
which really looks like this.
It has something for healthiness and metadata info
method.
It grabs series.
It
also grabs label names and values,
and it scales a lot because now
every component speaks with this API. So you
can integrate
Thanos,
for example, querying
to query from totally, you know, separate systems
like OpenTeesDB
or
or some other remote try remote read component
or totally different database rating as long as
it speaks this API,
which is which tries to be very efficient
by by by doing streaming and and compression
and so on.
So, really, that's that's most of it.
Obviously, Thanos has its own UI. Actually, recently,
we wrote we rewrote this in React, which
is kind of a bit more powerful than
the Prometheus UI.
But at the end, everyone just uses Grafana
dashboards.
But, still, this is very useful for ad
hoc querying.
There is this bucket viewer, so another kind
of interesting UI that Thanos adds on top
of Prometheus.
But, actually, we we we will play with
that hopefully today as well.
And I want to, last but not the
least, I want to mention, you know, other
kind of aspect of this Thanos community.
On top of, you know, contributors,
we are super proud to have, like, kind
of strong mentorship programs.
Thanks to the CNCF as well and other
mentors.
And so we have really, you know, diverse
amazing people at SM and T. Some of
them, you know, end up being maintainers.
So
just for all the old projects out there,
open source project, please please mentor because it's
actually a good good way to get to
give opportunity for for these people to have
career
good career and actually contribute to Thanos in
the same time or, like, your projects. So
it's pretty pretty pretty amazing.
And, yeah, I think we we might be
ready for some action.
I think yeah. Let's let's talk for that.
I think that's it. Yeah. Alright. Awesome. That
was a
that a great introduction there. I really like
that. I wasn't aware of that mentoring program.
That's awesome as well that you're, you know,
helping people break into open source and development,
and then they're even becoming maintainers or contributors.
So really cool program.
Yep. It's really hard in the beginning to
kind of
jump over this first barrier of of the
time and sacrifice,
but it's super worth it long term. Like,
really, like, open source is really the same.
Right?
Yeah. For sure.
So let me
pop up our screen here. So we if
anyone is curious,
wants to, you know,
go into the Thanos website, it's available at
Thanos.io.
There are guides that we're gonna
ignore for today
because we're living life slightly on the edge
with a demo that you have prepared
that you think works. So
we're
gonna see how we get on with that.
And if people want to play with this
demo as well, it is available on katakoda.com/bwplotka.
If I click on start course here,
there's actually a few which I'm assuming
people can use as well, but we are
gonna play with the secret Rawkode demo resources.
Do we wanna just
talk about why we're going down this road
rather than the documentation
for people? Like, what what what is different
from the approach that we're gonna take today?
Yeah. That is the very good reason behind
that. And by the way, just maybe let's
start. Like, there is officially,
like, katakobah.com/Thanos
where we are publishing, you know, production ready
ready, let's say, tutorials and demos.
We
have kind of large base of those demos
which are in progress. It it takes a
bit of time to prepare them.
And
so they will be like, all of those
that you you've seen even on VWPodka,
they will be published soon as well. So,
you know, if you want to, like, nice
experience, just just let's wait for them or
help us contribute
and and and do them. But at the
end,
we prefer doing those Katakata tutorials versus documentation,
like, you know, guides and whatever because it's
super interactive. Right? You don't need to have
your own machines, really. You can just run
all your comments, all your Docker, you know,
machines, ports, even to to to some virtual
Kubernetes that is
running, and you have just the interface
and just terminal connected to that through the
browser of Katakoda. So it's extremely, extremely amazing.
And we are abusing this a lot because
every time we have conference
and we need to create a demo, we
used to do it on our laptop, but
this is that this doesn't scale. You cannot
play with this demo easily and maintain
that
because your laptop is different than, you know,
Mac OS running somewhere or laptop that someone
else is using or or Windows machine or
anything like that. We totally break this barrier
by just every time we do demo conference,
we do it on Catacoda.
And, actually, we're literally streaming Catacoda
kind of browser and how we do this
and explain that maybe with our own words.
But after this, we just
describe the
what what has to be done in this
tutorial,
kind of nice, maybe kind of cleaning this
up and publishing this as a proper tutorial.
So it's not wasted time. That's kind of
our goal.
So really the same we are doing here
now today.
Yeah. I just echo everything you said there.
I think KataCode is such a much more
tangible learning experience for people, you know, being
able to actually run the commands and get
hands on it rather than just maybe reading
the code in a a tutorial. I think
it provides a really good platform for learning.
And you're getting a lot of love for
the mentoring program as well. So firstly, you
got a hello
followed by the Thanos has the best
mentoring community of open source and then a
wee plus one. So you know, whatever you're
doing there is working, that people love it.
Keep it up. That is awesome to see.
Alright. So the difficulty on this is is
is YOLO. So I'm excited. I like it
when things work, but I like it better
when things break. So we'll see how that
goes.
It's worth to mention that we want to
take it a level higher. So we don't
want want don't want I mean, we will
not use Catacoda to run the comments. We
just take and copy them into your
VM,
which makes it more interesting, I guess.
Yeah. I mean, if you want to up
the difficulty a little bit more, I can
go spin up an ARM machine on Equinix
metal, and we can see how the ARM
compatibility is.
Yeah. The only problem, do we have connection
to that? We can, like, we can spin
up UI and and see those things as
well?
We'll we'll we'll keep it simple. We'll do
it on my machine. I I just Oh,
yeah. No. If if you wanna update difficulty,
we we No. No. No. Let's start with
the machine.
At the amount of times, I've had people
on this this show, and I said, oh,
should we do it in our machine? And
there's just this fear. They're like, no.
Not yet.
Alright. So step one
is we are sorry.
On your go.
Yeah. Let's how to do how to do
it properly? I think
we can I can describe essentially what is
happening here? So first of all, I think
it will be best to have some data,
like some metrics data that we can play
with and maybe, you know, query against and
stuff. So let's generate that. That's that's kind
of the the comments here. I think
you need to first
have this card here variable
in your lap on your laptop or something.
You can indeed copy this.
Yeah. Yeah. It's yellow, by the way. Yeah.
Oh, that's the wrong command. Yeah. Yeah. So
it's actually this is not copying. This is
executing.
So I'm
sneakily
yeah. You need to just copy it manually
this time. Rest should be fine.
Okay. So the first command is to pull
down and run a container with the Thanos
bench image. What's the Thanos bench? Correct. The
Thanos bench, you can actually go to maybe
GitHub page for that. So it's githubcom./Thanosio.
Thanos,
actually, with hyphen I o. Thanos hyphen I
o. Yep. Yep. Click it.
So it's our, like, benchmarking
slash testing
library
or, like, kind of client CLI.
So you can generate yourself from queues blocks
or from to use wall even or things
like that. You can generate some load.
So we will be using that to generate
tons of blocks because, you know, we want
to test unlimited retention,
so we're gonna generate one year of data.
Nice. Okay. Cool.
And only five series, so we don't need
to wait too much.
So we created some profile.
Yeah. I recommend you to copy this and
just just run on your machine.
And this is essentially showing how the planning
works. So this is, like, command block plan,
and block plan will just generate,
essentially, a configuration for further Thanos bench command
that will actually generate blocks. So you can
actually cut this block,
yeah, block spec dot YAML, which should be
generated in your directory right now.
Yeah. And this is, like, just raw YAML
that specifies how the block should should look
like.
And this is kind of the input for
the for the further comments. So this is,
like, really
a row method JSON. How how the just,
like, low
low level format of the totiz d b
block, which is exactly the same block that
well, this is, like, Prometheus format, but Thanos
is exactly the same format as well. Actually,
Cortex uses that as well.
So you specify some kind of meta JSON
metadata of the block. So how what's the
retention of the block? And then if you
scroll a little bit down, you kind of
define series in a very low level stuff,
and this is like your load generation
stuff that you just provide some names, some,
you know, type goucher or counter,
and maybe the variance.
And, like, this is, like, whatever is to
kind of whatever is easy to to to
to kind of generate
somehow realistic data. Right?
So we're gonna generate couple of blocks with
five series. So there is no need to
kind of scroll it more. Yeah. It should
be on your data. So now if you
copy another command, this will
generate the same plan
and just pipe it. So pipe actually the
same JSON into
the
block again. So another command of Thanos bench
and output this in directory,
which will be called, yeah, from e one
replica zero because
I I should mention,
I I it would be nice to kind
of create
to showcase all or show showcase kind of
the benefits of Thanos. So we need more
than one Prometheus. Right? So the idea is
to create free Prometheus and simulate kind of
two clusters.
One cluster e one and the one e
US One.
And the first one, e one, will have
two replicas of Prometheus. So we can imagine
they kind of scrape the same applications
from your cluster,
and then U U S One, it will
be just one replica scraping, you know, U
S One cluster. Let's let's imagine.
So what we want to do, we want
to create data
backfill kind of data
artificially for three of those. So that's why
you need to copy three times,
and it will but just generating data into
three different
directories.
Right? Yep.
Okay. So you should have, like, three directories,
and all of them should have,
you know, one year of data, hopefully.
Yep. We got from US One, from EU
1, and from EU 1 replicas.
Okay.
Super cool. K.
And next, I think we will try to
get configuration
for the from users.
Now you can also copy this
file, the whole thing,
and just it will produce a configuration file
into,
yeah, Prometheus e one, replica zero config, and
three of those, essentially.
The interesting
part of this Prometheus configuration,
if we look on that,
is really what it is doing and what
external labels it has. So you can kind
of talk for that a bit here.
Yeah. Perfect. So this is, like, the basic
configuration you need to have.
Global, so the global per all scrape configurations,
you need interval. We just make it faster,
five seconds, so it collects
the data, you know, faster.
And
we need external labels. And this is very
important point because Prometheus
have this as an optional thing. You can
just mark Prometheus
as
identify
Prometheus as something, so using external labels. So
whenever you query this Prometheus
from outside, like federation or remote treat or
something,
those labels will be attached.
But to in Thanos, we use it extensively
to either identify permit uses among, you know,
know, humongous amount of users you you you're
you're running. So
it's really
recommended to specify, you know, the cluster,
maybe replica, maybe zone,
and tenant because we kind of you know,
we have
tenancy model based on those labels as well.
And what is Prometheus what this Prometheus is
doing is essentially scraping itself
because it's running as 93, so it's scraping
itself. So, yeah, that's that's the whole thing
that Prometheus is doing right now.
Okay. Awesome.
I really like the Thanos bench tool. I
can see loads of different applications for that.
Yeah. You can actually yeah. It's not Thanos
only. Generate only stuff for prem users. Yeah.
Because how else you can test down sampling,
right, or stuff that you write for long
term duration metrics. Right?
Cool. It was it's a it's a challenge.
Like, I used to work for influx data,
the the company behind influx d b, and
trying to give people datasets where they can
walk through these contrived situations for down sampling,
alerting, and notifications are normally detection is is
actually a really difficult problem and Thanos bench,
you know, I wish I had known that
existed
a while ago. So we've got our data
written for three different Prometheus,
Promethe I. We've got our configs
and now we are going to expose some
port configurations
for each of these.
Well, actually, I like that you've got Promethe
c's, Promethe I, and Promethe
I. You can choose you can choose how
you call it. Actually, it it was trimmed.
There is prometeous instances as well. You can
free there are free ways how you can
call multiple prometeouses. Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. So we have some variable
environment variables for ports. You run locally, so
please copy the the second one. It's essentially
some some
variables useful for UIs
just to not
copy them around always. Yeah.
Yeah. My computer was
playing.
There we go.
My old tabs are broken.
Let's see if it crashed.
There we go. Right.
Alright. So we have exposed those previous addresses.
And now I'm assuming, yeah, we're gonna run
the Prometheus. We just show a help if
you want, or we can just go through
and and run Prometheus.
I think
it's not Prometheus deep dive where you can
do that as well.
Up to you.
No. You you you choose. You're the one
guiding me through this. What makes more sense?
What do you what do you want to
do? So let's let's copy the docker run
with help so we can see what's going
on. This is, like, official image
version two twenty. If you do it, you
should see some help and actually pull it.
It will
probably take some time.
And this is how you run permit uses.
There are lots of configuration
flags,
and tunnels follow the same path. You mostly
have flags to configure stuff. So okay. Let's
not
dive into this too much. We can dive
on on the maybe first from queues that
we run. So let's run from queues first
and talk about the flags that we actually
use.
So we have three of those. Right? Again,
you can actually run three of those, and
then we can talk about flags if you
want.
Yeah. Let's get them I'll get them running,
and then we'll Mhmm.
One,
two,
Three.
Alright. So let's quickly talk about this configuration.
Right? So we have for this one, this
is, like, u s one
promotuous because
it gets
the configuration from from US One replica. We
need to share those
file configuration file with from the local machine
to Docker, the same with the
data
directory
that we generate the data to,
again, from The US replica zero.
We name it this
okay. But the flags are the most interesting.
So this is really standard kind
of command, let's say,
and how you deploy it.
The tricky part is that the retention time,
I increase that to, like, thousand days because
we have one year of data. And by
default, prem queue starts with two weeks. So
if I when I started this by default,
I just seen two weeks because it just
deleted, you know, immediately.
And there is this tricky one,
max blocks duration, mean block duration. This is
essentially
disabling local compaction.
And what it means is that Prometheus is
compacting those blocks periodically
to optimize for Prometheus use. However, because I
arranged that and and generated those blocks as
as I wanted with whatever yellow durations,
it will just start compacting for no good
reason,
and we just don't want this. But, ideally,
you can
if you have prompt queues with such long
duration like one year, you want to keep
this option
like, remove this those flags because you want
compaction to be enabled and even with Thanos.
So this is only for demo purposes.
And really nothing else like those enable life
cycle admin APIs.
I think this is
I don't think this is really needed. It's
it's really to get
nice APIs like delete series and snapshot for
Prometheus. So
this is it. This is just running Prometheus
with longer retention rate. Yeah.
Okay. We can actually play with it. Just
just just go
you don't need to click this because it's
hard, you know, to open in your machine,
but just go to local host and nine
zero nine one, which is, like, the first
sprint use. We can see if we can
access our data,
and we don't.
This is Yeah. There's no ports exposed.
I think
because this is the
we know what's happening because this is
Mac. Right? Mac OS.
But there's there's no dash p on the
docker. That dash dash net equals host, but
probably on Mac OS that doesn't work.
Ah.
That's the problem. Okay. That's fine. We we
Oh, we we sorry. It's okay. We can
do docker for Mac.
I think it tries to resolve that for
us. That would be nice. There is a
thing.
Yeah. Let's either we can do this or
we can modify with minus piece everywhere.
Let's
Yeah.
I run it with a minus piece, so
that might be quicker. I can't remember what
the Docker for Mac name is to resolve
to the
let's see.
Or Mac
domain Mac.
About host.docker.internal?
I'm not familiar with that flag.
That's no. No. Sorry. That you have, like,
docker.forward
for Mac. It's like host.docker.internal,
I can read, but, you know, I'm not
a Mac user.
Neither am I. I'm a Justin Painter.
Have Most. Sorry.
You I I I have that in the
chat as well.
Oh.
Let's try this out. A host. Sorry. Yeah.
Alright. Okay.
Host docker
internal
9091.
Okay.
So let's pull up code. I'm just gonna
do this.
And this is the 01,
so we'll do
90919091.
Copy.
909.
Was it just 909190929093?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Replica one. Replica one. What about
you've got 1111.
And then I'll just copy the US One
so that I only need to change the
network. Let's try gateway one more time. That's
the last thing I found on Internet. Gateway
to docker.internal
on the web. And then because this will
kind of
help us a lot. No. Okay. You can
arm. Okay. Let's put minus piece.
Well, this it can't be magic. Right? Docker
must write something to the host's file.
Nope.
Docker binned is the Docker internal. Yeah. Kubernetes
dot Docker. But
this is weird. Yeah.
Maybe it's by cube.
Yeah. There's nothing else.
Chat, please help us.
That doesn't work like this.
I
should know what that is. Maybe it's in
the DocuSign. We'll we'll just spend a minute
on this and then I'll rerun the containers
for that. Yeah. Exactly.
So
settings.
Leave it down from here. Network.
Subnet.
Docker for Mac DNS name.
Yeah. Let's just say goodbye to dot dot
go and use Google.
Host dot docker internal, we tried.
Gateway, we tried.
And none of those are working. Alright. Let's
just rerun the containers.
Did I copy the US One? I did.
So we take off net host.
P9093.
Alright.
There is, like, reverse panel thingy that we
can start.
Actually, that might work.
Do you want me to go with the
tunnel tunnel approach before I blow these away?
No. No. No. No. Let's start with minus
p right now.
Alright. Okay. So let's paste all that in.
Because the tunnel has before all parts. Okay.
Alright. So we should now have those all
exposed on our local machine.
Alright. So local host name o name one.
There we go.
Cool. Alright. Let's check any of the metric.
Insert metric cursor
cursor, it will
there is, like, a yeah. Or I can
start typing. Yeah. So we have, like, five
series, as I mentioned. And then if you
go to graph,
tap here, and just go one year instead
of one hour because why not?
Usually,
this is impossible, but we generated stuff and
not many series, so it's totally fine. So
we can
we have
five series, yeah, for one year, and this
is
what we can do in for
now. So let's try to
kind of solve the problem of kind of
maintaining those premises on scale. So we want
to have a single query endpoint
that will span over those permit users and
get all those c five series, but from
each of those.
And in the same time, we allow us
to de duplicate
this replicated one because as you remember, 9091
and 9092
are replicas.
So if if you go to 9092,
it will have exactly the same data.
It will look exactly the same. So you
can actually, yeah, just do this. Yeah. It
will be exactly the same if you could
kind of map because this simulates the situation
where those two Prometh users are scraping
scraping the same applications. Right?
Cool. Let's go get that. To our tutorial.
Alright. So now Yep.
Now kind of this is the time when
we when we feel this kind of
horizontal scalability
and adding different services around microservice,
really, architecture. So we start with sidecar to
expose our, you know, powerful gRPC store API,
as I mentioned. So let's add the sidecar
to each of those from users to expose
this gRPC endpoint really.
And, actually, before that, maybe let's go through
this help, dash dash help, and we can
spend a little bit more time here because
Thanos was always, from the very beginning, just
single binary. So we have all components, all
microservices
here.
So you can see you have,
you know, sidecar,
store gateway, like store,
courier,
ruler,
compactor,
kind of many, many tools. Where
extends extensively adding more tools that you can
kind of maintain in your data in easy
way.
And then at the end, we kind of
added kind of new components. If you scroll
down, receiver
and query front end for caching. It's not
even properly described even
yet. Alright. But this is how you run
all comments,
all service by just describing a sub comment.
Right?
Okay. Nice.
So single binary,
but each of those can be run-in
isolation.
So Correct. Okay.
So right now, we will deploy sidecars
to each of those.
And you need to probably copy and make
sure
we add m minus p.
Yep. So
dash p and this is Well, we we
want gRPC we want gRPC endpoint, to be
honest. So
just just one port is fine.
Nine one nine one nine. So
correct.
So we don't need the HTTP port at
all?
I I I mean, exposed. Like, so what
what's what's the difference between the gRPC? What
are the responsibilities for those two ports?
Yep. So
first, HTTP is responsible for any UIs you
have because, unfortunately, our browser doesn't speak gRPC
yet.
However,
it is useful also for debugging endpoints.
Right? So, like, metrics,
traces, debug, whatever.
The gRPC endpoint is for our store APIs
And
and, actually, not only store APIs. We have
other gRPC APIs that maybe other components can
can
expose.
And because we want to kind of communicate
for this gRPC, we need kind of two
ports.
And
Let me just grab this last one.
Okay. I can see one kind of issue
we need to solve.
This sidebar has to speak through the HTP
with the Prompteus
sidecar with the Prompteus. You know? So you
can see we specify Prompteus URL.
So we need to find a way to
actually get that routable to Prompteus.
Yeah. Okay. So we can do an alias.
It's actually okay. You need to do this,
above, I guess.
Not be with them because slide power is
a sub command already. Yeah?
Yeah. Here.
Alright. So what we need this one has
to speak to
this container here.
Correct.
And we'll call it just prom, and then
that just means we can use prom here.
No. No. No. Not here. This is exposing.
This is exposed,
so let's expose properly. And then from this
yeah.
What? Super nice.
Alright. And then we need this container ID
for this one.
Prom.
I like to talk to myself when I
type. It keeps me right. That's good. That's
good.
And finally,
we'll use this one.
Oh.
Well, that was that one. Okay.
Let me make sure it didn't break the
last one.
Yeah. I skipped one. Okay. Cool. Mhmm. Mhmm.
Prom.
But yeah. And we need to replace prom
here.
Alright. So
done, done, and
done. Let's see what happens. Let's
see. Double check. Yes. Looks looks fine.
It's not alias. Let me
link, isn't it? It's link, not alias.
Link.
Take two.
There we go.
I'm assuming if they did not exit,
that's a good sign.
No. I mean, they will exit in the
background. So we will never know until you,
yeah, talk about us. Do you want me
to put a logs on one of them,
or are we are we No. I mean
confident?
No. I mean, it should be I mean,
we will see on the further step. Right?
Then we will start debugging. So the last
point is to have our query engine to
be put in a separate microservice.
So this is kind of a querier,
so a query subcomment.
Yeah. And with the exports. And
so sidecar configuration is pretty pretty basic. I
think we didn't touch on that yet, but
it's really it is actually capable of reloading
configuration
from use of the of from use configuration
and evaluating
the environment variables as well into this configuration.
That's super useful in Kubernetes.
And then and then you can even compress
using gzip
your configuration of from to use. Sometimes it's
really, important,
especially if you want to use Prometheus operator.
And this, you know, uncompress evaluate environment variables
and poke Prometheus to reload configuration. So this
kind of nice,
small, tiny feature of sidecar as well.
And
for courier, we need to expose
to a p to two ports. Yep. And
we are exposed properly,
and we need to leak to to sidecars.
Yes. Correct.
And
So this got linked to the sidecars,
not to the Promethe I. Right? Sidecars. Correct.
To the gRPC of sidecars. Yeah. So this
is
prompt zero zero.
We need prom zero one and then prom
u s.
Prom Is it is it right I think
it's not right place you are putting it,
but that's fine.
I mean, you need to probably fix it.
Is it it should be in the link.
No?
Ah, you are
correct.
So that should be
oh, undo.
Okay.
Alright. So prom zero
it's prom e U 1 0.
Yep. That's the first one.
So we call this prom e u one,
and that becomes Prom E U 1 here.
Yeah. Correct.
So k. The the thing the thing that
you you can specify, the dash dash store,
is the, you know, endpoint of story API
that you should target
in order to fetch metrics from for this
query evaluation query engine. Right? So
you can also put, like, in more complex
environment, you can put DNS endpoints so you
can actually resolve those automatically.
You don't need to put it manually.
So that's a choice as well.
Okay. Let me run this and see Yeah.
If it yells at me. It looks okay.
I think that's okay.
Alright. Let's it it so Queryr actually exposes
the UI, so we can look on that
port.
Nine zero nine zero. Yep.
Okay. And stores, if we do click stores
page on the on the head. Yep.
We can see that
we have free store APIs and only one
kind of works.
And we can see that by
I mean, I assume so because we have
announced labels set only on one. And this
is our those those are actually
external labels that we
and they are correct. But for some reason,
we don't have from other stuff. But okay.
Let's query. Let's see how query behaves,
what we can what we see there.
Yeah. Let's fetch this metric again.
Alright. Looks like we can what what is
happening is that probably.
Yes. So I mean, I I guess I
to the Prometheus as well as the sidecars?
We already
no. It's a sidecar that proxies to Prometheus.
So this link doesn't work for those two
sidecars,
and for one sidecar,
it works.
And it doesn't work for
yeah.
I didn't get that which one work, which
not.
Yeah. So I would mention Prom 9093
anywhere here. That was only in the sidecar.
That that's okay because sidecar is is what
matters here. So sidecar somehow doesn't work
in this configuration.
So let's see. We have
okay. Let's attack US.
This
from US 10
Port, this
looks fine.
Actually, we can also
look on logs
if you want
of the sidecar that
might tell us something.
Maybe this idea is wrong.
Oh, yeah. It's wrong
because
you took it as
yeah. That's fine. It's actually yeah. We don't
need actually from curious logs. It's a sidecar
that is broken. Okay. So what is happening
probably is that you
took this in order, but, actually,
the order was switched. So the container
you pointed to is wrong, so it exposed
in a different port.
So what is happening is that
sidecar with for for the ending with free
points to one and and so on. So
you need to replace
Okay. Well, you added names to these containers,
so let's just use them instead of the
IDs. So PromUSDash1.
Okay.
Let's just not use the IDs at all.
PromU11.
And this one,
prom u one zero.
And just so the names are consistent and
I don't trip myself up,
e u one one
say car.
Let's call this prom.
You can just copy maybe.
Yeah. I should have copied. Okay. So PROM
EU 1 and PROM EU 0.
Fine. Yep. Perfect.
PROM
EU
PROM EU PROM US.
And this one here,
from US One Zero.
Yeah. And there are hyphens as well you
need to fix on the from e u
prom hyphen e u hyphen zero.
But down
below, you have without hyphens. So
Perfect.
Yeah.
Should be fine, of course. Yeah. See, every
time something goes wrong in this show, it's
always my fault.
Always me.
I should learn to be more
careful.
Alright. So let's Mac OS fault this time.
Yeah. We'll blame Mac OS. Okay. So let's
delete
So we'll delete the query here.
We're deleting all the sidecars.
Mhmm.
And that's it. Right? Yep.
55 is the wrong ID. Oh, yep. Because
I meant to type 66.
Which means we should only be left with
three Prometheus running.
Okay. Correct.
Now we've got three new sidecars and a
new quidier.
They seem happy. So the the name in
Twitch worked.
Run to stores.
Oh, we have labels now. So Give them
give them a little bit time to to
to so just refresh maybe. Maybe it should
be
So I broke in the US One.
Okay. Let's focus on this US One then.
Oh, that's not got sidecar in it.
Okay. So I can just delete the query
and run that again. Yeah.
I will fix my code. Don't you worry.
Alright.
It's gonna work.
Ta da.
Yes. Super nice. Okay.
So
so this page shows you, as I mentioned,
you know, what's the APIs we have in
the system. We have only sidecars. You can
see that on the header. It's a sidecar.
You exposed every replica.
Sorry. What are the labels announced from each
of those premises so you can either identify
kind of your state store API.
You have meantime and max time. Those are
the durations
that you
durations
of what time range you have
of the data in those in those print
users, kind of,
and then, yeah, like,
health kind of status. So if you go
to graph
and try to grab those things,
we have
right now two responses.
Without going to graph yet, we let's let's
talk about this. So we have one series,
but, you know, just to
continuous up metrics, but just from EU and
US cluster. But as you remember, like, we
created three Prompt users.
However,
I mentioned that replica
sorry. The the U U One cluster from
users are in this mode.
So they have
they are scraping the same data. So we
are a courier and Thanos is duplicating
this
in runtime. And we can see that if
you click the duplication the duplication button.
So turn the duplication off and then query
again, execute.
So now we can see that those were
masked,
and they were no. Like, the the rep
the replicas are masked,
thanks of this replica label.
So because one was stated as replica zero
in external labels of Prometheus, one replica one,
This was reduced essentially and the duplicated. So
this is how you define
h eight mode.
Right? And if you go to the Thanos
querier command that you run, so the Thanos
querier docker, maybe
if you
just go to that Docker run thing, you
can see that we specify query replica label
equals replica.
It will query sub command addresses, and then
this
is how you tell what label you should
kind of choose to duplicate from by default.
And, also, you can specify many of those.
Right? It doesn't need to be just one
label.
Nice.
So this is a global view for querying.
We are planning to add even even more
kind of resources you can federate because this
is kind of federation.
Let's check if we can actually
retrieve one year of data as well so
we can graph them.
Cool. So
we have still one year, and
the mode
is is super nicely kind of transparently duplicated
so we don't need to worry about that
from the user experience. So it's pretty accurate.
That's that's what I'm saying. And
it also fills the gaps, potential gaps that
PromptUs will have.
So
if you would kill PromptUs, one of those,
it will user will not spot it. Right?
So you can totally
do rolling restarts of your Prometheus. You can
upgrade them. You can change configuration, whatever, and
this will not disrupt your query and availability
kind of. Right?
Very
cool. Cool. And that was the easy part.
Was the easy part.
Because this is just global view, and you
can run Thanos in this mode. You can
just add sidecars, have a global for the
rated endpoint,
and
and keep it like this for your system
or for your part of your system.
However, we can go farther and talk about,
you know, cheap storage
and long duration
of those metrics as well in a cheap
spay in in a cheap, yeah, space.
Cool.
So are we going back to the tutorial?
Yes. And continue.
So
last page, second page is around long
retention.
So now let's spin up some object storage.
Thanos supports, you know, of any any kind
of object storage you
want, like, very, very many clients.
But Minio is one of the s free
endpoint kind of API supported
object search. You can run locally on your
disk. So let's run it.
Cool. Cool. Cool. You can create Thanos bucket,
or you should, actually.
And we can
actually check if Minio is running.
Yeah. We can don't click that. You need
to probably go to local host 9000.
Yeah.
And the access is Rawkode
and Rawkode
something.
Rawkode loves OBS.
There we go. Correct.
So,
yeah, we should have a bucket ready, but
it's empty, right, because we just created buckets.
So let's go and check how we can
back up our data from Prometheus that Prometheus
collected into this object storage.
What we need to do, we need to
reconfigure our sidecars.
And first, we need to create this configuration
file. It doesn't need to be filed. It
can be passed through the flag as well,
but let's configure a file. This will be
easier. You specify, you know, the type as
free, maybe GCS, maybe Azure, whatever,
and some configuration dependent on the on the
object storage. So
Okay.
So Menio has a name of Menio. So
that means I'm I probably wanna change that
configuration file.
Or Yes.
Yes. Yes. And then we need to make
sure we have Menio everywhere.
In actually, there will be only
couple of components that will access object storage,
but then we'll refer this as media. Perfect.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool. So we wanna stop three saved cars,
and then we're gonna
Reconfigure.
So run them again,
but with a couple of flags.
And shipper
I mean, how we gonna do? So maybe
let's Just because you have them flags? Exactly.
Actually, there will be one more, but let's
copy them first.
Okay.
So So this this is
the those two flags are configuring or well,
passing
object storage configuration to sidecar. So now it
knows there is object storage, and it will
upload every block that will appear on the
Prometheus local directory
into the
object storage. And then you need the
no. No. No. Sorry. No. No. No. The
actually, both of them. So there are two
minus
did you copy all of them? Alright. Alright.
Because right now, we need to without the
name, but that's fine. Yep.
Yes.
Correct. Perfect. So what is happening here, we
added configuration
to Menio,
and, also, it has to access
the directory
of of Prometheus that is is accounted for.
Right? Because it needs to know whenever Prometheus
is actually
kind of
dumped any block or not to have it
uploaded to to the object search.
Okay. Let me just check the US One.
US replica tier. Okay. That's fine. So I
just need to add one more link,
which is menu. Yes. Menu.
Easy.
Mhmm.
I shouldn't say that before it works, should
I? Okay.
Alright. So we wanna stop the three say
cars.
See in fact, let's just do docker container
l s.
GREP
say car.
30817.
3 0
C C.
Alright. Good. And run.
Yeah. Oh,
wrong And
the object for the flag was we need
to be after
sidecar subcomment.
Yeah. Those two flags are the Thanos flags,
not Docker flags.
Yep.
Alright. Let's try that again.
Okay. So it's maybe working.
Correct.
They've not crashed.
So how do we confirm?
Can we just look in the bucket?
Yeah. Maybe.
Just open
the Thanos.
Click on Thanos. I think you need to
click on Thanos bucket, sorry, to see
so if you go to menu browser again,
just click on Thanos. Yeah.
Okay. Something
is not exactly working. So let's check
sidecar logs.
Thanos ship
No. So ship projection is just side effect.
I think the problem is
read open
dot data. No such file or directory.
And this is because it's not data. It's
Prometheus. Right?
It's
we
this is because you copied and kind of
manually added the flag, but that's fine. Let's
this is not the problem. The problem is
that the sidecar has wrong direct so we
shared the directory with
with host directory with from e one replica
zero directory into Prometheus
directory, but let's do it slash data.
Sure. I put because
I altered how
yeah. And looks like the default
is slash data, and we need to do
that for all sidecars. Yeah.
Because if not, we need to manually change
the flag into prompt queues to point it
to prompt queues, but this should work. Yeah.
Yeah. I hope so. It's
Uh-huh. 306.
B 9 9 9.
Cool. No. It looks like we should see
that in the browser now.
Yep. There we go.
So they're using
menu as an s three compatible
object store, and Thanos is
writing data to it. Right? Yeah. Normally,
it's recommended to use s three and GCS
and Azure whatever it's much it's actually quite
cheap, and it's
reliable. So they do backup. They do you
know,
they scale it for you so you don't
need to maintain your own hard hardware ready.
It's very cool.
What are the I guess there's a performance
trade off there for storing my my data
here. Right?
Like on the query side, that must I
guess it's is it slower?
Yeah. You need to kind of maybe
add more caching and and kind of essentially
use more memory and CPU than normally you
would use just to have those caching mechanism
and and avoiding great limits. And this is
the whole complexity is an in another component
that we will run right now,
which is store gateway. So this is the
component, the microservice that
kind of understand the object storage and the
format inside and expose that as a store
API.
So when with some gRPC API that allows
you to query this data, and this is
where the complexity of trying to avoid this
latency penalty is there.
I mean,
is
yeah. The whole complexity is there, but you
are right. Like, Prometheus
or, like, Thanos,
well, you you want it's not like
low latency APIs.
Right? You you can wait
seconds for your query.
Over ten seconds and, like, ten seconds may
be painful for experience, so you want to,
you know, scale it accordingly.
But you can totally have sub seconds or
sub five seconds with a kind of results.
I guess the the best practice here would
be to layer your data. Like, would you
use the SSD desks for all data that's,
like, two weeks old? And then and if
an older than two weeks, you could store
an object store where maybe you can accept
that extra latency on the read side. Is
that Correct.
And you can totally do that. And, actually,
this is naturally by default what is happening.
Right? Because
as we will see, the uploaded data
is for, you know, older data
that was stored and collected by Prometheus. Well,
we generated, but normally, it will be collected
by Prometheus.
The the
the current data of Prometeos, so the first
three hours of the data are stored in
memory in totally different format,
not in the block, TSDB block. So you
only have data in the object storage after
three hours.
So that's why you need to still and
we will see that. You need to still
query prompt queues for this fresh data.
At least in this deployment model when you
have
just sidecar uploading the data from prompt queues.
Right?
So, yeah, let's actually try to fetch use
this data. Right?
So we have kind of two more components
to go and to one to actually fetch
the do the querying site against the object
storage,
which is
store gateway. Yeah. And this guy needs to
have access to menu,
just menu,
and expose gRPC port.
Okay. So that's Exposing.
One yeah. For
yeah. Correct.
And it needs
link menu menu.
Mhmm.
This fail is
fail. It's correct.
Yeah.
Oh, that's it.
Yep.
Okay. So this is a component. You can
scale that accordingly.
You can
you can have store gateway per each interval
of time. You can have
store gateway per different blocks. You can chart
store gateway
and tell that, hey. Have some consistent
charting
and and allow five, let's say, store gateways
to choose what blocks you are
you are responsible. The the store gateway is
for responsible, so you can, you know, horizontally
scale like this.
But let's actually
adjust the querier so you have that on
tutorial as well. Now we need to adjust
the the querier to know about this new
store API that just appeared.
So here, we just added a new dash
dash store. You can just copy this one,
just last flag,
and then we need to add accordingly
the link as well to this one. Yeah.
So this is an gRPC endpoint of the
store gateway. So let's do that.
Okay. So we are doing this.
Oh, yeah. I'll just type it. Store. Yeah.
This actually is yeah. Yeah. Good. Yeah. Fine.
Correct? A store And then we called that.
So And we need link as well. Yeah.
Yeah.
Link.
Store
gateway
from store.
Mhmm.
And let's,
yeah, let's run store gateway.
I think we run it already. Yeah. And
then Yeah. We do. Query and
run again. Yeah.
Yeah. Usually, it's just easier in Kubernetes where
you define this
infrastructure using code, unfortunately,
or, like, some YAML templates,
whatever.
But there is lots of manual work if
you are running Docker. Yeah. We have start.
Right? And you can see that announce labels
are now
three of them because we store in one
object storage, like,
we call it streams of data.
One stream per each unique.
Right?
And store actually properly even says how old
data you have. You have data from
year old time
until today. Right?
Cool. So let's play with it. Can
okay. Okay. Let's go to graph graph
graphing, and let's graph again one of the
metrics.
Cool. And now what is happening is that
okay. Well, this is actually expected.
Do graph.
Yeah. And I will tell you why. Because
you are checking you are checking the last
the recent data. However, Prometheus is not collecting
this artificial series. Right? It's collecting their own.
So this is why,
you know, this is in the block. Right?
Yeah. Okay.
I understand that. So if I change that
to year, we're gonna get data which is
coming from the object store, but that one
hour failed because we have now that data
now lives in the Prometheus memory.
Well and and to be honest, it's not
collected anymore because we artificially created the series
and we create artificial blocks.
Whatever is collected is actually its own
Prometheus metrics. It scrapes its itself. That's why
we don't have this particular. So there are
two reasons why we had don't have recent
data. However, let's go further and ensure this
comes from the bucket. Right? Because right now,
this query or funnels query into all of
these sources. However,
I can, let's quickly showcase the debug kind
of way of of of doing this. So
if you go to new UI,
this is kind of new React UI, which
is pretty similar. Unfortunately, you need to type
the metric again. Continue.
Yep. You need to go to graph again.
Maybe I because it's recent data, so you
won't see it. Correct. And now you need
one a year, and enter doesn't work into
to execute. Well, I think we need to
I have this fixed.
Okay. And now we can see the same
data. Now let's do this. Let's go above
and scroll up a little bit. There is,
like, enable store filtering.
This allows us to filter stores. So let's
pick
any of those and, like, four is the
store gateway,
or or we can pick one yeah. Pick
this just to show that we'll only route
to
to first from queues. And as you can
see, the series is e one
team u. Right? Mhmm. This will route only
to one of those store APIs if you
want to debug what is coming from where.
Right?
And if I change this to
this one? Then it's only a bucket data.
Right?
It's fine.
Okay.
And
we have twelve minutes, I guess. Right?
Yes.
And we could quickly,
and it'll be super nice to add
a last component, which is kind of interesting
here for long term maintenance,
compaction,
and
the duplication offline duplication as well and
downsampling,
lots of features. So this is a compactor.
So kind of, you know, local compaction of
raw materials just taken into microservice again.
It has to be singleton.
It has only HTTP address because there is
not no gRPC
kind of it doesn't expose any metrics. It
just works on the bucket.
And and periodically,
it's like a batch job, but just periodic
that performs those operations.
Now what we need to do, we need
to probably link to menu.
That's the only thing because it operates on
bucket, and we should be fine.
Okay. Before we start, let's talk about quickly
the the flags because they are not trivial.
The compact
as a is a subcomment, then we have
wait. So make sure it is, like, in
a
in a long running service manner. It's not
like a just quick batch of, hey. Do
the operation and done.
And then we make
it more often. So the interval is pretty
quick. It's half a minute
for all those compactions and downsampling.
We change consistency delay. That's I could talk,
you know, long about this, but, essentially, this
is feature for
buckets that are not eventually con not not
strongly consistent
because not all of them are. Right? So
to resolve this without strong coordination
between components and stuff like that, which makes
it super complex in distributed system world,
we are introduce other mechanics like delays
to wait until the
consistency will be up. Right? So we disabled
that. So we
expect we essentially use the blocks
no matter where it when it were uploaded.
So we assume that the the the bucket
is consistent because it's file system. Right? Almost.
And that's it. Let's try to run this,
and it will allow us to
so it will try to compact things,
but it should actually quickly
downsample data, hopefully.
And I want to show one more kind
of feature of it.
Cool. Looks like How we do we see
the
compact? I I guess this is what Okay.
No. No. No. Yes. We can see operation,
but there is cool cool stuff. Go to
the HTP port of the
compactor,
which is oh, I don't remember. One One
nine zero nine five.
Yeah.
And, sorry, and slash load load it.
Perfect.
So this is a and kind of and
bucket view, but from the perspective of being
block aware.
Actually, go to new UI. It's much nicer.
We are kind of in transition period.
So you can click on each of those
block. Stores are blocks and eyes of it.
You can click of them,
and it will show you all the metadata.
So its ID,
duration,
how many series it have, how many chunks,
samples, what resolution you have, and
labels. So you can see we already within
one stream, we have three things.
One is the raw data, but what you
clicked is actually a resolution. And this is
one hour resolution. I can see by resolution
equals those are seconds,
something something seconds. Right?
And so we can see it already downsampled
everything because, yeah, the blocks were super small,
so it was quick.
So this is how you dev up stuff
on your object storage. Was super cool. It's
super easy. We want to extend this view
as well. We want to make sure you
can even download block from this point of
view or
maybe do some actions like delete series, delete
block, or but you it's essentially a bucket
viewer like you have on AWS,
but block aware. Right?
Awesome.
So can we I I
I'm trying to understand
this. What do the colors represent here?
Different resolution.
Right?
So this is the resolution zero. So raw
data, whatever scraping interval was, this is
raw resolution, which means that
you have all the samples.
When you go to the
lower resolution,
it has it is still accurate.
However, it only covers the aggregates. Right? So
it,
have all the averages and maximum and minimum
to make sure your queries are accurate.
However, it doesn't cover,
all the samples. Like, you don't know exactly
in what moment this happened.
In the resolution five minutes, you only have
one sample per five minute.
And then in the blue thing, it is
one hour resolution. You only have one sample
for
one hour.
And this is super crucial when you are
querying long time ranges. So, actually, let's go
to the querier, and I I will show
you.
So
okay. Now
this is this is good. We are actually
only
querying the bucket because only in bucket we
have downsample data. So that's okay. Let's keep
this filter on. And now we are
querying only raw data because you have this
only raw data selection. You see?
Yep.
Try to execute it a couple times first,
and then you see the load time. Let's
remember this. This is, like, six hundred milliseconds.
Right? Mhmm. It's pretty quick because series, there
are you know, blocks are small. Now take
it to the only raw data and max
five minutes downsampling. So this will use five
minute
resolution
and execute couple of times as well.
It should be actually quicker. For me, was
quicker. But okay. Six times quicker. Right? Because,
actually, there are six probably
around six samples less times less. Right?
Yep.
And if you go to one hour, it
will be broken,
and this is the same.
Somehow,
this artificial data doesn't work well with one
hour down sampling, and I need to debug
this
Same moment. Okay.
Let's just I'll go back to five. Oh,
look. Yeah. Yeah. It would be cool. Let's
cut it.
Anyway, this is what I wanted to show
you, really.
And as you can see, if you go
to to through roll roll data or downsampling,
within one year, it's accurate. You don't need
so many samples. It it cannot render anymore
even. Right?
So there is no need to get and
select from the back end so many samples.
That's why it's it's it's it's much efficient
and and actually
cheaper as well. Right?
Okay.
So one one more thing I want to
mention is that, you know, this is like
a global view tunnels deployment. There is also
this approach of
configuring permit use to push data, remote write
data, like Cortex is doing,
to
to your
component called receiver,
which is then uploading to back end and
connecting to query on all of this. So
this is also flexible on that, but this
is kind of the default mode you can
run Thanos with.
Yeah.
Okay. Is
that is that everything?
Looks like it. Yeah.
That? We can well, we can we can
if you want, we can play more. We
can break up. We can
Oh, no. No. No. No. I was I
was being entirely sarcastic. We have covered so
so much. That is a lot of awesome
information and I I love the categorical work
that you provided here to walk us through
each each of those steps. I think that's
gonna be infinitely valuable to people. I just
wanna let's try and see if we can
surmise this in in a couple of minutes.
So what your categorical tutorial has walked us
through is one,
using Thanos bench to generate
artificial
time series data
at any scale that we want. Like we've
seen the flags there, we could have tweaked
that and played around with it. That was
really cool based on a YAML definition.
We then
started three different Prometheus, one in a European
replica situation, replica zero and replica one for
high availability of that Prometheus region.
And just another Prometheus, which was our US
region data.
The tutorial then guides us through deploying a
sidecar or another container in this example, which
acts as a proxy to each of those
Prometheus
followed by a deployment of the Thanos querier,
which speaks to the sidecars and fetches the
data doing
de duplication
based on the label configuration that we provide.
See that alone,
would have been awesome.
But then you just you kept it coming.
We then looked at how we could use
the new UI. We got block storage through
many or any other s three compatible store
and then you even threw in some awesome
downsampling at the end. Like there is so
much valuable information here that I'm gonna have
to rewatch this episode a few times I
think just to consume it all. That was
awesome. Thank you so much for that.
If anyone has if anyone has questions, you've
got a couple of minutes to get them
in before we wrap up and we'll do
our best to tackle them.
I will make sure the show notes have
all these links as well, links to the
docs.
That was really really cool. Thank you for
taking the time to put that together and
then not only that but walk me through
it and live debugging our container setup as
well for a Mac, which was just made
it all a little bit more fun. Yeah.
Yeah. You're welcome.
All of this should be part of the
official Katakoda tutorials for Thanos, hopefully. So this
work was not wasted,
not a waste of time, and only one
of timing
thing.
We it will be useful for people
because we went for that. Right? So that's
that's pretty long term useful as well.
Yeah. I I I I can immediately see
the the problems that, you know, Thanos is
is bringing to the Prometheus setup. I think,
you know, everyone running Kubernetes is in this
situation where they want to improve their observability
and their monitoring. And, you know, the the
tools that are coming out to help us
do that, I think, is just phenomenal. So,
you know, I also thank you for your
your work on these projects as well. I'm
making this almost
really consumable to anybody that just wants to
improve their setup. So that's great. Yeah. Yeah.
And and but, you know, there are still
lots of things to do. So please, you
are welcome to contribute, give feedback.
We are exploring way to get those metrics
data
into analytic platforms because since you have long
term, you know, duration of the metrics, you
want to leverage that for
reporting, billing,
or really just artificial
machine learning, whatever,
AI.
So we are doing lots of work on
that.
And we all we do all of those
in the seek observability meetings, which are
kind of announced on the CNCF page. So
please feel free
to to join us as well and learn
more about those. But yeah. And, yeah, thank
you, David, for for having me. I think
it's super, super useful for everyone to keep
doing this.
I can learn about CNCF project I never
seen as well. So That's cool. I know.
I I I love that I've been working
and focusing so much effort on the show
the last few months because there's just so
many awesome projects in the CNCF landscape and
you know, like getting people like yourself, the
experts that are doing this day in and
day out and having them not just, you
know, do the technical walk throughs, but bringing
your knowledge and your experience and sharing that
with people, I think is incredibly valuable as
well. So
Yeah. Totally. And I think the problem is
that they the those projects
and and maintainers between I mean, you know,
there's really no communication between those projects. Everyone
has its own echo chamber, and this is
really bad. This is really sad as well.
And not that they do that on purpose.
It just people are busy. Right? So Yeah.
It should be amazing to just to share
the same problem and solutions we have, and
we solve the same problem. So I'm doing
your work. Actually, yeah, pretty sure I'm pretty
sure it helps a lot as well on
this on this point.
Okay.
Well, thank you for your time. We've been
a little bit over, but I think it
was definitely worth it. Remember, people check out
the sec observability of the invites in the
calendar. Get contributing there. Keep an eye on
the Thanos mentoring program if you're new to
open source at Thanos and want to go
through that program.
And again, thank you for joining me. Have
a great day and I will speak to
you again soon. Thank you. Have a great
as well. Cheers. Bye. Bye bye.